welcome to the iron Lords podcast
all right and we are live Laura Cognito
here iron little podcast launching
gaming.net with the amazing dance from
Plunder panic and who is this fine
gentleman in the realm today
and then what is your role look from the
planet well I'm one of the founders of
the company we'll win games uh plunder
Panic is our inaugural title and I was
one of the totally designers on the game
awesome so for the realms for people who
don't know what Thunder Panic is
describe to the realm about this
character yeah it's a uh accent arcade
game we say it's a Swatch buckling
action arcade game we're up to 12
players to play together we have the
whole yeah most of the Lord's here and
loads of gaming so 12 players yep so
we've got uh you know red Zion and a
blue side red you know you guys should
all be red I think awesome
um and there's multiple paths to Victory
so you can sink the enemy ship you can
plunder gold from the world bring all
the booties
and uh you can also kill the enemy
captain and since eventually take over
their [ __ ] awesome so let's get an idea
of this game plan what's going on right
now yeah we got Lord King right now are
you plundering King yes I am
legendgate.net how are you doing break
it break it down that's won the game
I went into their ship and I took the
gold out of their chest so you took the
beauty and you went back
so I'm sorry but you can explain what's
going on for us yeah so that was the
plunder Victory you know we got the uh
the Royal Navy got the gold in the world
um and we have multiple game modes so
this is just free play now okay so to
just go right into another another game
but we also have a conquest mode where
uh you have to get one of each Victory
condition okay so that allows the other
crew to kind of start you know defending
against that other condition that you
know the team is missing so all right so
like let's say if under all the gold yep
and and uh the next one to see the ship
exactly yeah so again with the multiple
moves now with the free play this is
just caught with free-for-all like what
is the whole premise of free play
specifically
uh it's basically to win as many rounds
as possible gotcha yeah okay okay yeah
so as we see right now we see people
swinging from the tree we got the
Cannons going on what's going on with
the guys down there yeah so the remote
is full of TNT if you get it over to the
enemy ship and you blow it up so so yeah
it's it's essentially a button Masher
down there people get in and row the
boat you can get your crewmates in and
kind of rush it but then of course the
other team can get in there and
encounter and if you go down with a
sword you can just kind of clear it out
that is hilarious
from the customization I mean from a
character standpoint we have preset
characters that everyone picks from
correct or no yes three set characters
currently yeah we have these fun Little
Pirate characters awesome awesome so I'm
defending the remote now so I'm clearing
out all the Redskins
those guys are the robot they're trying
to get that TNT over yeah
now from the combat standpoint is it on
one hit like kill situation and and the
response like how does that work so I'm
the crewmate since one hit you know
um if you're a captain you've got a hat
and if you get hit you lose your hat and
then if you get hit again then you die
awesome awesome and as you can see
there's a lot of items in the world that
you can pick up so there's like a
blunderbuss which is like a gun that you
can pick up and shoot uh there's a
little we call it the cursed Idol that
if you pick it up you can throw it
toward the enemy and then uh on this
level these meteors rain down wherever
the cursed idle is that's right
now this cannon that's at the top of the
volcano yep
that was funny
lemon they stole the booty song what's
going on hey stop what's happening
fruit
awesome but I was going to ask you about
that Cannon is that something that the
player control or take uh okay yeah so
you pick up cannonballs in the world you
bring them up and load the cannon okay
so Bob it you know it takes a while to
shoot so the the opposing side to
counter it with a sword they can cut the
wick awesome
um or you know if they don't get there
it goes off and you gotta hit them three
times to sink the ship got it got it
you're so good so when you get a little
Cannonball just run up to it
what's up
you can initiate that no no Gene what
were you doing during that uh pirating
run you know well everyone's battling
I'm sneaking
this is awesome now I see a different
stage here you've got like the different
like almost sunken bolt vertically thing
going on yeah
and how many how many different stages
do you have so we currently have eight
our plan is to have nine at release so
we're in Early Access right now on Steam
for Windows and Mac okay but we're
releasing across all the major consoles
nice and uh likely June of this year so
likely do yeah because this thing would
be like the ultimate quantity game I can
totally see you know a Nintendo switch
Xbox Live Now what do you think about
considering online personality as far as
um the multiplayer for right now is
strictly the couch Co-op situation so
yeah we started completely couch Co-op
and uh we went into the pandemic and it
was illegal to get old people together
so then we're like hey we need to Pivot
and we basically rewrote the game from
scratch nice to support both counts go
off and pull multiplayer awesome so you
can have three people on your couch and
connect with you know behind other
friends all over the planet yeah
we have we have a matchmaking like a
casual matchmaking that eventually we'll
have a great play uh method because
there's also private rooms that you can
have where you can fight your friends or
you have a room code that you can share
that's awesome that's really cool let's
see what's going on on the second team
see how they figure it out all right
y'all got the ski okay you're getting
the plundered out here what's going on
we just need to come they thought they
told us how to get weapons oh so now all
right so they're down
got it down
are you are you ready to plunder and
pillage
let's go
how many streets
you got his hat King
what a great Dragon TV in the building
yeah
there you go there you go who rode the
boat
who's rolling the boat all right I just
saw a
mermaids each levels have uh different
uh threats in the water okay so if you
fall in the water basically it's showing
you that there's something down there
and if I fall in the water here I I die
you know so that keep focusing on me so
like one's a shark one's a mermaids
they suck your battleship again
just for fairness yeah we got to give we
gotta give the second team of iron Lords
all right
all right round three
let's go
sense action plunder Panic y'all this is
what it is love this stage
yeah
this is kind of our haunted stage yeah
we release this around Halloween
love it love it so again the basketball
yeah you can play you know you can play
one player you know and we've got you
can fill in the teams
um you know you can do asymmetrical
teams or you can do like four versus
three if that's what you got and the the
victory conditions balance yeah for
example like how would it balance in
that perspective as far as like an
uneven team or yeah for example you
would have to kill the enemy Captain
more times they would have more lives if
uh or you would have more lives if you
have less players
this gentleman right here I'm very
interested what's going on yeah so he is
uh effectively known as swabi okay
also runs the sword shot okay
there's a sloppy on each side so he does
two things one is uh you bring bold to
him and he gives you a sword okay the
other thing is he keeps the deck clear
so you can't have other players camp in
there got it and okay got it yeah
exactly all right so let me get some
some plus information so solve addict
how's it looking yeah
you know oh somebody got in the book
somebody
now I see that shifting oh the tooth is
two holes on that red chair one hole in
the blue shirt
let's go it's going intense here with
your lunch right now everyone's talking
down here
killed
and a little thing they're saying that
again
that this is how it's gonna go
appreciate that
all right
so what is it it's two two one
okay okay let's go
here we go now I see Luther right now we
have a whale it's not a killer dolphin
it's a killer whale yeah wow
yeah yes
and this is our newest stage here it's
still kind of in development but we
wanted to show it here on the show floor
awesome it's a cherry blossom level so
um
cherry blossoms in a game automatic
needle love it
again
[Music]
so look this is absolutely fantastic
those are your Victory conditions y'all
what's up buddy
again
they did it again
absolutely amazing again for the people
who want to learn more about fun to
panic give them that information one
more time where can they find this game
when he's about the release of the
platform yeah if you just go to
thunderpanic.com you can get all that
information right now it's out on Steam
and early access for Windows and Mac it
will be out for uh Nintendo switch PS4
PS5 Xbox One and Xbox series X hopefully
in June of this year awesome
yes awesome
gaming.net plunder planet
hilarious absolutely fun go check that
out
[Music]